When I read the right value, it says download or install the latest frequency updates. These will keep your machine running cool and I prick frequency peak efficiency. How do I do this?
Okay, so make sure that you have your computer in airplane mode all the time. So always have your computer in.
Airplane mode. And the reason is as we don't want you to do airplane mode. And the reason is as we don't want you to do, we don't want you to be doing any windows updates.
So if anything pops up on your computer, hey, you need your Windows update. Do not do the Windows update. Don't do the Windows update. All it's going to do is update a whole bunch of malware and garbageware on your computer so they can try to sell you different programs and different things. Do not do the Windows update.
Should you do a right update? Yes, you can do a right update. Really maybe once a quarter run the right update. If you don't run other right programs other than what I created, you literally never have to run the right update.
So my computer, I only run the right update about once a year. So, but if you're running a lot of other programs and you're interested in maybe some like
COVID programs, the newer programs that are out or something like that are a new flu program. Well, then you need to run the update. The instructions on how to run that update are on the on the member site, the right section of the member site. However, it's super easy.
If you're going to run a right update, you have to connect the computer to the internet. So you have to turn off the airplane mode and turn on Wi-Fi. So you're only going to do it just to run the right updates. So you have to turn on Wi-Fi, turn off airplane mode.
And then in any program, in any of the right programs, you'll see on the upper right hand corner, the bar, it'll say update frequencies. Just click that. You literally take two minutes to update your frequencies, dependent upon your internet speed.
And it'll say all done. Well, then put your computer back in airplane mode again, and you're done. So there you just updated the frequencies will not change your program that I wrote for you. So don't worry about that.
Do you recommend that I turn my machine on at nine o'clock and turn it off after the program finishes before I go to work? No, you could just let it time out.
Just turn it on when you go to bed and you're going to be utilizing it. And then just you can let it time out many times I never turn it off.
There's times that I get up and I like the switch and just turn the toggle off on the machine that will stop it right there. You certainly can do that too.
Where can I purchase the maryatic acid to clean by I am pro wave. Any hardware store, you can buy that at any hardware store. Just go and ask for the maryatic acid any big box store will have that too.
What is the terminal matrix heater and tube? And would I need that for my treatment of brass cancer? No, you don't need that. The heater is is a heater.
Another apparatus that rife sells to heat the iron pro wave water. If you're in a really cold environment and your feet get really cold really quick and you're doing an hour long program in the water gets too cold for you.
That would be the only reason why you would use the heater to keep the water warm.